الى متى برايك يستطيع نتنياهو ان يقاوم
ضغوط اهالي المحتجزين الاسرائيليين في غزه
ويستمر في هذه الحرب بشكل الذي عبر عنه في
مؤتمره
الصحفي ربما لا اجد انسب من معبر عن هذه
الحاله التي يعيشها نتنياهو ويعيشها كبنه
الحرب هذا الثنائي الذي ظهر معه سوى ما
قاله الون بن دافيد المحلل العسكري حينما
قال اليوم يبدو اننا بعد 70 يوم من عمر
هذه المعركه لم نحقق شيء ولم نصل الى شيء
لو عدنا الى الخطابات التي قدمها نتنياهو
واعضاء كابينه الحرب منذ بدايه هذه
المواجهه حتى هذه اللحظه لوجدنا انها ذ
اجتراح ذات المفردات نفسها وذات الشعارات
الكبيره هو يتحدث في العموميات وكل منهم
بالمناسبه يتحدث في العموميات ويهرب هو
وكبينه الحرب في هذا الحديث العمومي الى
الامام يتحدث عن تحقيق اهداف كبيره عن
القضاء على حماس وحماس ما زالت تؤلمه
وتوجعه وتوقع في صفوف خسائر وما زالت
تتمكن من اطلاق الصواريخ يتحدث عن استعاده
الاسرى وهو يذهب يوميا في سلوكه الى
القضاء على الاسرى واداره الظهر لهم
وقضيتهم نتحدث عن السلطه واسلو وهو الذي
يعني عاشت اي اوسلو في كنفه اكثر من 16
عام وهو الذي ما زال يتعامل مع مع السلطه
في الضفه الغربيه ويعتبرها شريك رسمي
يتحدث
عن قضيه ال عدم الرضوخ لمطالب حماس ويفوض
رئيس الموساد لمفاوضات حماس عبر الوسطاء
للوصول الى صفقه هذا هو نتنياهو يهرب من
مواجهه استحقاق الفشل المتراكم بالحديث في
الحوميات وربما كان من اللافت للانتباه
بان كل منهم من هؤلاء الثلاثه الذي ظهروا
الذين ظهروا في المؤتمر الصحفي في تحدث
بصوره الانا وكان كل منهم يحاول ان يستعرض
بطولاته الشخصيه وربما انتبهتم بانه حتى
التواصل البصري ما بين هؤ الثلاث كان
منعدما وفي نهايه المطاف خرج نتنياهو
منفردا دون شريكيه في كابنه الحرب هذا كله
دليل واضح جدا على ان نتنياهو لا يملك
استراتيجيه ولا يملك لملء الفراغ الذي
يحدث يعني هذا الفشل المتراكم منذ بد هذه
المواجهه حتى هذه اللحظه سوى باستم ضخ
الاكاذيب والتضليل والشعارات الكبيره
وبهذه الطريقه يهرب نتنياهو الان هو يقع
بين فكي كماش فك الضغط الداخلي المجتمع
الذي يتعاظم كما اشارت مراسلتكم ويبدو بان
نتنياهو يريد ان يتعامى عن هذا الذي يجري
والضغط الذي سيخلق ايضا تمنع المقاومه
موقفها الذي اكد عليه اسامه حمدان يوميا
بانه لا عوده الى موضوع التفاوض في ملف
الاسرى دون وقف الكامل للحرب هذان الضغط
بالتاكيد سيسرع في يعني خلق حاله مجتمعيه
ضاغطه واعتقد بانه المجتمع الاسرائيلي
ذاهب يوميا باتجاه تعاظم هذه الحاله
الشعبيه طبيعه الشعارات التي تطرح اليوم
انا استمعت الى اهالي الاسرع الشعارات
ليست فقط من باب العتب هي تدين المستوى
السياسي الاسرائيليه تحمل المسؤوليه عن
القتل اليومي هم يتحدثون عن اننا يعني كل
ساعه تمر في هذه الحرب ستعيد ابنائهم
اليهم ابنائهم اليهم في اكياس وفي اكفان
وبالتاكيد هذا المشهد اخذ في التعا
ونتنياهو يعني وكانه يضع راسه في الرمل هو
واركانه الحرب الذي مع لكن في ننتيجه سيد
محمد في النتيجه هو مستمر في حربه يعني
على الرغم من كل الحديث عن العجز اي لدى
نتنياهو وعن الارباك الذي يسود صفوف مجلس
الحرب لكن هذه الحرب مستمره كما يؤكد
نتنياهو وهي على ارض الواقع كذلك على
الرغم من الخسائر الكبيره التي يعترف بها
جيش
الاحتلال ايه بالتاكيد هو لا يملك خيار
الا الاستمرار في الظرف الذي يعيشه شخصيا
في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي في هذه
الادانه التي تتعاظم حوله في من حتى خصومه
السياسيين ومن قطاعات وشرائح واسعه في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي هو لا يملك الا ان
يفعل ذلك السؤال هل يستطيع ان يستمر في
التعامي عن حاله الخساره التي والاثمان
الباهضه التي يمنى بها شخصيا ويمنى بها
المجتمع الاسرائيلي في مستوى الخسائر
البشريه والاقتصاديه وحاله ال يعني التفكك
الاجتماعي التي تتعاظم في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي لا اعتقد بان نتنياهو يملك
كامل الوقت في هذا الامر 70 يوم واكثر مضت
على عمر هذه المعركه لم يحصد اي هدف
بالعكس هو يقدم يوميا مزيد من الخسائر
تقدم جيشه مزيد من الخسائر في كل
المستويات وبالتالي الرهان الان على
الميدان كلما ضغط الميدان على نتنياهو
كلما اعتقد بانه اعادوا الى الى ارض
الواقع وال سيضطر في نهايه المطاف ان
يتحدث باللغه واقعيه ويتعامل مع الواقع
نعم